[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we have mr.
Clyde STIs yeah
the co-owner of bills bees doesn't say
he's a good friend of ours but he's one
of those guys good friend after you have
one conversation with him and now we've
had two you just feel like man this
guy's a great friend I wish he was my
granddad yeah I wish he was my resident
beekeeper well he is he is essentially
we met him when we filmed the episode
10,000 B beard where we put the B beard
on link with a life
it was the GMM series called back up man
yes and that was a life defining
experience for me right and so he works
because I didn't die I got out of all
those B's I only got stung by one one
the very last one pretty much it hurt a
lot and bill of bills B's works with
Clyde and Bill is the one that was
actually in the video quite a bit yeah
but Clyde was kind of behind the scenes
and we talked to him and he was a
character and had a lot of crazy be
stories yeah so we decided to bring him
on to your biscuits until he's gonna
tell us a little bit about some of the
crazy things that happened to a
beekeeper such as himself I think some
life-saving advice is is gonna become
way we this podcast could save lives the
lives of beat the disc this podcast
could save the world
it could I'm gonna go that far no and
this is no exaggeration the but let's
just leave it at that
let's just not say this podcast and what
Clyde had to say could save the world
yeah right we're not gonna build it up I
mean you don't have to keep listening I
mean it would be your loss as a world
lien there are that term I am so thirsty
at the end of this day I know you're
resistant to this but but IRC anyway I
know you think it's because we went in
the ocean we went in the ocean this
morning and I'm not saying that doesn't
happen
impact I mean I don't seem any thirsty
or that I normally do that's why I am so
in touch with my personal hydration and
don't deny it don't deny that you're in
touch with your personal hydration yes
I'm not trying to read this
confrontational but I know that your
your hydration deny uh I would just say
so in touch with my personal hydration
that's that you should listen to me
that's the charitable way for you to say
that you're a very high sensitive when I
am sensitive to hydration I am sensitive
to my body and sensitive hydration low
temperatures
well let's not bring to this has nothing
to do with temporary this could be a
good thing I mean it can be annoying but
could also my you're now making a list
of things that you're annoyed and I'm
since if one of these days were in a
situation where like there's a killer
and he's and he's controlling our
hydration and he's slowly decreasing our
hydration and that's like you know what
he's killing this slowly by dehydration
you would be a great asset there and
this would be the one that knew that we
were having less water I'm just saying
I'm not sensitive to that I'm not gonna
tell you that I'm thirsty I'm just gonna
drink the normal amount you know what I
don't expect you to be and I will gladly
be that for you but why don't we do not
being that today by saying what why
you're thirsty and why we went because
we got in the ocean and and I've been
thirsty all day and I think that's just
my point you get in the ocean your body
maybe you have a leak I mean honestly
maybe maybe it's a skin issue maybe
there's like a hole in you somewhere
maybe you've got a hole somewhere that
you so III don't know it but I think
that's scientifically I mean and what do
you have another orifice have you have
you'd listen have you looked at every
part of your bottle for orifices where I
go to the dermatologist every six months
to have them do a full-body check for
orifice for other moles and if there's
another or if there's another orifice he
will see it he's never seen it he's seen
every square inch of my body doctors
places that I've never seen places that
I've never ventured to look at in front
of a mirror or with a video camera just
give it to me straight
do I have another orifice but you know
but sometimes you can see a big mole and
you might be tempted to think it was an
orifice and so you got close enough to
if it's dark enough
hey man we're in total agreement and
what I'm saying is having one of those
arguments about nothing you may have an
extra orifice in what happens when you
into the ocean is the salt comes in and
the good water goes out and it's been in
that or acid for physicists has been
leaking yeah but you could just coughing
you could just [ __ ] it you can need to
get some like dermatology [ __ ] that's
probably a thing they probably got some
up next time in fact I've got to go to
my dermatologist in about three weeks
psych chewed it straight man you got
caught you guys you got caught for an
unexpected orifices hey man I'm here for
one item one reason own [ __ ] for days I
want my orifice cocked the one then that
one orifice how that happened so we went
to the ocean and I think it's because my
body's not used to being in the ocean
water and I was ya with drawers we we
went surfing I'm not gonna say paddle
boarding because there's a stigma
there's a big stigma even though that's
really what we did but we were surfing
waves on paddle boards but let's just
say we were surfing because there's no
stigma it's cool and I'll say you know
asylum first time in over a year over
your body my body wasn't it was it was I
think it was acting as if I was in a
pool and not the ocean and it were you
gotta give it a way too much salt and I
couldn't I didn't know how to tell it
you didn't close it's gonna be saltier
than you're used to and I gotta say the
main reason we haven't been is because I
injured myself over a year ago and I've
kind of reinjure do my back I'm afraid
to go what else and you're afraid of
sharks why is the long drive and you got
to get up at like 5:00 a.m. yeah put
boards on a car and you need like but I
haven't been able to go on a bit I
haven't been able to go and you know
that if there's a shark attack they'll
probably go from me first cuz I'm bigger
it's like they go for the big seal first
right and you're all be home a big seal
you're always got your bloody and you've
got that extra orifice that probably
confuses sharks it's like an octopus put
some sort of ink hole it doesn't come
out of it really
so you know where it is now so I got you
you've got one yeah you've got what and
I'm speaking of the stigma I will say I
was thinking about the stigma because of
our recent conversation with our friend
who were both getting to know who will
remain nameless you don't want me to
name or him yeah whoever but when we
told him that we were stand-up well
first of all we we found out that he was
a lifelong surfer
grew up in Santa Cruz
Malibu for a while go to the boo every
every Sunday and he's like a legit
surfer he referred to his collection of
surfboards as a quiver I mean this is it
this dude is for real and we were
sitting there and we're becoming friends
with him and I was like you the funny
thing is you didn't even want to tell
him very funny but that's but I I just
felt like you wanted to hide that from
him but one of these days he was gonna
see the big s you pee on top of your car
or in the garage or something well I
mean weird is a fledgling friendship I
wanted to know I wanted to bring
judgment I wanted to break the seal
during our like you know third or fourth
interaction because I didn't want that
to wait and become awkward because I
know how surfers feel about stand-up
paddleboarders I don't know you know
this but they hate us and they call this
cooks and they they think that were
dangerous because we are because we have
basically large boats that were standing
on that can kill people and we don't
really know what we're doing I have
nearly killed myself four times yeah and
other people know where the other
orifice came from yeah was it accidental
I gave myself an orifice but when a
near-death experience but what I will
say end up paddleboard in defense of us
is that we know that we're not good and
we're a lot better than that we made a
video one time as part of the mythical
show the very first time we ever went on
paddle boards that's on the Internet and
we were horrible in fact so many people
we were so bad people thought that we
were doing it on purpose we were jumping
off for the comedic effect and no you
just sucked so bad it was like the board
was totally steady and then it was like
yeah and we've gotten much better than
that but we're still very cognizant of
the fact that we're not liked out there
and accepted so we go to places where
it's more acceptable for stand-up
paddleboarders there are other stand-up
paddleboarders and we kind of stay in
our lane so to speak and I got to say
you look you look good today you call
something now I did look back there a
couple of times and saw you lose losing
your balance in the middle of nothing
and just falling over so it still does
happen and then while you notice that
then you lost your bite so you see the
other guy fall it's like yeah you lose
all perspective but I I feel good about
it it was a a soul fulfilling experience
and we
to do it more man we got to do it more
it there's a zen-like quality of I mean
I'm not gonna go so far as to be like
the electricity there's electricity
involved but there is I mean the
electricity and everything okay so you
are going that and then the one that
what's the next step that there's a
connection I don't know but I'm just
saying I'm not there's not it's not what
I'm talking it's nothing you're not
gonna go with the cosmic connection with
the ocean right like it's a living thing
but I saw a black bag but I also saw a
dolphin
yeah so I'll try I'm somewhere in the
middle there's so much trash I saw I saw
like a black piece of bag and I saw a
harbor seal I saw a crackerjack box and
you saw a what of a fish rock a human I
mean we see all these types of things
yeah so there's a there's a tension here
but there's a zen-like quality to being
out there that it just I mean all day
I've felt well dehydrated but also just
like like I just have more space I have
more space in my life mmm
what's the waste the water that you
leaked I have more space I think you
know I'm filling it up all day but it I
feel like beekeeping and we'll get to
that you know it's a whenever we talk to
Clyde what we are to talk to a boat in
that conversation I just feel like this
guy has a little bit as in he's got
space because he works with bees and
there's a resonance to it or something
so are you it's just leading to you're
gonna take up beekeeping because that
doesn't sound like that sounds like the
kind of thing that I would try to get
you into well try to get me into it I'm
very susceptible you want me you want me
to get a hive if you want to if you want
me to get a hive then you you and I get
a hug yeah get a hive and then you know
I get a hive you come over every years I
don't have a hive and you want to take
the high thing you want you won't care
about it yeah I'm open to that I I feel
like beekeeping is the kind of thing I'm
gonna do in my old old age you know like
if that's in the meantime we need to
surf but what if there was a surfboard
had bees in it like you know there's a
if you walk up to a hive like we did it
bills and I'm I'm spitballing here
I can tell you can there's there's a
there's a resonance to it there's a I
mean he you know Claude talks about
dropping a mic in there and what he
experienced when he like listen to it on
headphones what if that was in a
paddleboard you mean there's ice inside
the board yeah well I think that's a
problem when you get in the water I
don't think the bees would be excited
it's uh it's breathable from the top
don't well how do they get in and out
don't don't don't lick the stripes off
my candy cane man listen I personally I
still you imagine being on I mean people
do yoga on paddle board it sounds like
more like an art project honestly it
doesn't sound like a sport it sounds
like maybe something you'd put in you'd
put up in the backyard it's like I don't
need you for this I've got I've got a
surfboard that I've hollowed out and I
put beehives in people love it I'm not
selling you one I'm doing it and
honestly it kind of hit me and Clyde or
do it sounds like a like a high school
art project he's already in he doesn't
even sound like something that would be
accepted at the Modern Art he's I'm
texting him he's texting me now I just
felt my I just felt a vibration
I saw his phone I don't think he tagged
and he's saying I've got the board's
I've got the bees Clyde literally had
I've got the Thai landline telephone in
his pocket that's not text but don't you
want it that your granddad I do but did
you sense that there was space in his
life all right for a grant he seems
really peace manchild
he seems very peaceful I think anybody
who is in touch with nature in that way
maybe that's what you're getting at the
resonance of nature I mean sometimes the
only thing we the closest we get to
nature is is the wood wooden tables that
we do shows on flushing the toilet you
know that can be a little too natural
experience it's like a like a whitewater
rafting experience well good luck with
your art project with Clyde we had a
great conversation with him it's not an
art project but we also want to let you
know that we've got a book ready links
book of mythicality we wrote it and here
it is look it hold that up look at that
now here it is it looks like this is the
book but this is just a book cover
that's that's how books work now this is
what the books gonna look like and this
is what the cover is gonna look like but
the book is still in process well if I
open this up I I mean open it I don't
know what kind of book is a braised
beets with orange and pecans it's just a
recipe book exactly what its gonna look
like it's the same dimensions as a
recipe book red links book of
mythicality a field guide to curiosity
creativity and tomfoolery
full of a lot of stories from our lives
our shared experiences 30-plus years of
friendship and how we've been able to
add through those experiences
mythicality to our lives
buy one for yourself buy one for your
friend buy one for your people who don't
have friends in the book can become
their friend you can pre-order right now
at book of mythicality calm that is book
of mythicality calm I am ready to get
into some bee conversation create some
space in your life for Clyde and us yeah
it's gonna be amazing it might save your
life and it might save the world here it
is so you were showing them pictures of
you sitting there beginning and during
the time you were getting the bees on
you and standing back here going yeah
yeah mutilated mutilating man I was
actually curious well you know that they
work here so they're quality they're
there they're required to watch all of
our videos well kind of the one young
lady said she hadn't seen it yet
yeah we're adding we add people to the
mythical crew and I'm joking we don't
make them watch everything that would be
like but that's the one I should make
him watch because that's the one where I
seem like a rock star
yeah and that doesn't
but many times well I told him to you
don't see it on film and everything
because you got it back here and you cut
and put things together but I said one
of the memorable points was he's sitting
there and the bees are going on him and
I says you know he loves to chat a
little bit
and he's going well like my mouth I says
and I remember him stating so clearly
tell me a story
take me to a happy place I said I was
waiting for him to spring from the chair
and run away but he didn't he stuck it
out but I said that was so merrily well
you told me not to run because then I
would have been yeah like ripped to
shreds by these bees potentially yeah
that's when you make them aggressive
right yeah but that sounds great
I mean bees devouring yeah that when I
would've gotten more views yeah if they
would have killed it was pretty epic
though it was also one of the best 20
minute sessions of my life because link
was completely quiet for the entire yeah
I couldn't talk process because we were
that's why we're trying you're literally
trying to get into your mouth yeah they
are I could feel their little fingers
trying to pry my little fingers or their
fingers their fingers okay so fingers
yeah there's what's on the end of the
leg actually you can't see it with a
naked eye but there's actually little
Spurs on there I know I but I could feel
those B fingers yeah the the B fingers
felt like little Spurs and they were
prying my lips apart to get inside of
yeah my head yeah yeah the moisture is
something right well that and it's just
a natural thing for them and they see a
opening and they want to investigate it
they're curious that's why you had the
nose plugs on yeah as well yeah we had
your ears and my ears were plugged every
orifice yeah is above the waist is
inviting I kept my pants on you had your
belts yeah we've done them before we did
there was a short-lived TV show on it no
but have you put it on yourself oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's on it's on a
short-lived television show yeah they
had his dating program or a boy meets
girl and you were the boy it would have
been nice but this was oh shoot we have
a young lady here and this was in plenty
of them listening but well this is one
typical silly girl that was silly silly
oh she just made so many actors going on
her first date or something but but you
were not a contestant on a dating show
the dating show came to get B's from you
to put on a to put on in a date
yeah well the boy and girl were dating
he was a beekeeper was it that naked
dating show you know that one yeah
meaning naked that's a freaking show
naked and dating yeah it's like it's
don't even afraid it's not even naked
and afraid he's just naked dating I
think yeah I think afraid is implied
well I think I would be afraid too if
you saw people look better with clothes
on mmm
depends on who they are okay of course
man okay you just applied the the beasts
yeah we just applied the beasts and to a
fully clothed woman who acted like a
child yeah well you have done it about
halfway through it she sits there and
tells the director the producers and
everybody and we're standing here she
goes I have to go to the bathroom well
that's not a possibility I said I looked
right directly at her and I says you got
to be joking she goes no I've got to go
to the bathroom I said tinkle in your
pants I says we can't stop she goes oh
you must you must
I says they cooperated you ranked all
the B's off of her you're giving her a B
beard on a date I still don't understand
well he was premise was he was a
beekeeper and he brought her out to the
be guards to show him what he does every
day and everything like this and that
was how he was gonna show her yeah
stupid well that's not how you get a
second date let me slay your face with
10,000 bees and and I don't even tell
you to tinkle first yeah well it was all
explained to her before
the cameras started rolling but IP
before everything that we do all times I
just peed well like when we were on
Fallon I mean there's like a nervous pee
that happens you went more than me this
time oh I didn't for nervous beats yeah
three or four you get your body
naturally evacuates everything it's like
a fight-or-flight thing yeah get
everything else you can be light you can
be spry you never know what's gonna
happen and you don't want to wet
yourself on on a dating show
well television as long as it's filmed
for above the waist you don't have to
worry about it see I mean that's why we
sit behind a desk but I would constantly
urine
we're like NASCAR drivers we did urinate
whenever it hits us do you know about do
you know about the NASCAR drivers thing
they have like a it's like a external
catheter that yeah that goes to the
bottom of yeah they have a drawer fit
and it goes right drawer yeah well it
the one that we saw was an external
catheter that went down which is
basically the thing that I wore on the
show the PPAC thing we tested a product
where it was for like when you're at the
stadium and you don't want to get up and
go to the bathroom and you have a
literal like bag on your leg Stadium pal
or something yeah yeah and I had such a
difficult time relaxing yeah and like
while just sitting there next to people
and doing that but NASCAR drivers those
guys that do the Baja 500 they do it but
it comes out a little too and just goes
through a hole in the floor of the car
well yeah yeah no no that's the part
that's the part see with everything he
says there's a part where you gotta be
like made up what's the made up part and
that was it I mean it's like an oil
slick for the for Earnhardt jr. trailing
you yes like it's like a Batman yeah my
urine is very slick for weaponized
purposes look at two hundred yards ahead
for the wet spots that's where we go
it's a trail that's what you can
weaponize bees yeah right yes looking
like you know how to do it I don't even
know what that means I've heard of like
weaponized bees but I don't is that like
you strap missiles on a bee no I don't
know what it is okay here about ten
years ago in that neighborhood a very
intelligent gentleman out of the
University of Montana
and some other places developed a
process of training bees so you train to
bees like a dog like a horse or anything
like this but they trained him to the
scent of gunpowder and they would put
gunpowder training to do what to the
scent of gunpowder they would follow
gunpowder they would go to it like he
would go to it like tracking it like my
dog tracking his scent correct so they
will track that gunpowder it takes quite
a long time and and you add a little bit
more and more until they start doing it
then you take it out in a field and you
put gunpowder down on the ground or
something like that you release the bees
and they will fly around and they said
of going to the flower they go to the
gunpowder
so why okay and then well that's the
application of that okay now the fellows
are suddenly lighted yeah now the
fellows are setting in wartime and
they're in Afghanistan and all around
and they got these landmines up and down
the roads and all around like that so
they've taken these bees and now they
release them they fly down the road and
they will hover over these landmines
landmines so there these are like a okay
so there's lenses so the Gunpowder in a
landmine er yeah same stuff and they
pick up the scent and so you're driving
down there and you're oh look if we have
one in the middle of the road we have
one over here one over there put the
brakes on stop get back people can go up
take care of that situation or drive
around it we're looking for bees to make
honey and we're delicious they're
beneficial to the military on that do
you know how they're training them
specifically what how do you get a D on
gunpowder or be attracted to it you know
you put it oh well let me guess I'd say
you put it in a you put it in a flower
you get like a little flower very much a
flower from what I've understood you
start off with honey itself a little
drop of honey you add a like peppering
the honey with a little gunpowder like a
little salt bay yeah a little salt me
and you you know about sabe you know who
did you know who he is yeah yeah but I
mean you turn around and you who is he I
don't some turkish butcher and he and
he's famous for putting salt on things
know what he cuts meat he's a butcher
that like is a performance artist on the
internet he sprinkles a song and then at
the end his elbow and goes all over the
meat oh he's a Julia Child
yeah he's the modern-day Julia Child's
of meat yeah yeah but does he say you
didn't know yeah that was your thing but
it's always best to send you do I'm not
much in Turkish meat turkey comes at
Thanksgiving yeah but you know my wife
puts turkey meat in the meatballs and
I've eaten it and then I might we know
there's turkey in there so well thanks
for telling me oh yeah I just afterward
yeah well it could be worse
I didn't mean to derail us but you did a
little bit they they put a little honey
good in there they add honey gunpowder
and then they just come yeah the bees
will naturally go to the honey fantastic
now why did the bees go to the honey I
thought they made the honey but what are
they also attracted to honey because I
thought they were attracted to pollen
they are attracted to pollen they are
attracted to the nectar that's in the
flowers too they want to go to but the
bee has never learned to not make honey
she will go to anything sweet just like
she you know she'll go to you guys we
talking about the Queen yeah
they go to the Queen they go to the
Queen they'll go to pop cans soda cans
okay cuz they're sweet
so yeah they put they know if they put
honey there the bee is gonna come there
put the powder gunpowder with it and
they come there what does the bee do
when it encounters hood honey if I like
just took honey and just hoodies not a
hoodie they don't care about hoodies but
if you just put honey on like a bench
yeah all of a sudden you have bees all
over it you can you're set out there
what are you thinking
soft drink like this is what we would
need to use to make what we need it is
the thing that we need to use to make
bread we had they you know they go to
they go to the easiest source so you
have it sitting here on the bench a tray
or whatever and there's honey there why
should i drive five miles to get a
little bit when i only have to go a
couple hundred yards because they're
just making honey to feed all the people
yeah so they fly over there they they
pick that honey up just like they would
pick the pick up the nectar and they
come busing back to the hive and they go
back over again and they don't
discriminate it's not like ah we didn't
make this they don't care as long as
it's sweet and then how do you get the
bees back into the into the hive after
they spotted something the bees will
collect themselves when the Sun Goes
Down so you just leave them where
they're at really but if you remove the
the mine they're just gonna gather
around that anymore just leave the bee
leave a collection box there with what
they're familiar with gunpowder they
when it gets dark they all collect right
back into that you can be making all
this up and we wouldn't know don't tell
him that no that's like open it oh no
somebody's gonna hear this again he's
flying well and here's the interesting
thing
ERISA is I know this from Bill explain
this to us that you guys have also been
used as like consultants on freaking
movies yeah where do you use this
consultants on the B movie itself yeah
it was mr. Seinfeld yeah this is I'm not
making this up they working to be they
need to be consultants for the B movie
or the guys yeah they oh well it wasn't
fantastic it like Jer a skin you
questions no we were mine was she there
no we we were characters yeah we
directly worked with the sound man
cameramen and people like this were I
was super intrigued when the sound man
came out and he set there and or stood
there I should say
he puts mics inside the hive we know
that the bees make different sounds at
different times of the day we know they
make different sounds at different
levels in the hive and this was one of
those very few times in my life I'll
ever again I was able to put a headset
on and listen as he recorded the sounds
of those bees at different levels
it's just overwhelmingly exciting that
was the best thing the best sound you've
ever experienced well my wife said yeah
I'll marry you sweetly and I'm the honey
man yeah and this last year that we she
said yeah it's been good after 50 years
well I think we'll make it a little bit
longer 50 years yeah so yeah there's a
milestone you're bringing home to honey
yeah well you let you bring honey for
your honey and you'll be happy happy
happy
yeah thank those things trying to make
it weird
but wasn't there like some major detail
I think I've ever built telling me this
there was some major choice that they
made yeah bill was like frustrated about
something that was like wrong wrong one
of the characters was a female and it
was actually our male yeah
they we gave him the 101 class teachings
about bees and when the final episodes
are all covered up and put together they
got drones flying out there and the
world because blossoming again and honey
is being made and it's happy happy time
again it was great and accurate drones
don't do anything they don't make any
honey they don't do any they just walk
around and eat and the worker bee the
lady bee does all the work according to
them mom just said in the house
and made supper and knit it and took
care of the kids well a point yes but
when all those drones line up like
soldiers and reevaluate the whole earth
and colors and everything I sit there
and I went no that's the exact opposite
of what happened al Seinfeld's character
who was a drone because he was a dude he
should have just sat there and ate the
whole movie yeah that would have been
accurate and it probably would've been a
better movie well and he should have
been looking like wow
where is there a beautiful young lady
around here that I can mate with I'm
looking for them that's all they're good
for right meeting a bit different kind
of movie let's be honest you call
psiphon thank you guys number 1-800
something something I think you gave you
the dummy number yeah you know you can
say it is but it worked out very well we
made money from it they did I should say
and you got paid something and there's
gotta be some money and some and be
consulting don't answer that
that's a tell us how much money you make
because we make it's not fair oh they
were very reasonable okay
very okay tell us if you want to tell us
no don't tell us cheap it were you stung
today yeah there was three or four times
this morning yeah really
I got out of the truck to put my bee
suit on and before I knew it I had a tap
in the back of my neck and a couple on
my hand and I says thanks ladies you
welcomed me here today
I mean appreciate what's the average
what's the average on a day others days
I've worked and not had a sting there's
days that I've worked and had a dozen
but I seem to remember you hanging
around with no bee suit on yes I had a
beard full of them yeah you know and I
wasn't not protected while you were
doing that but I also will say we
something we learned when we were there
is that that particular hive was at a
certain stage where they were like the
least aggressive that bees can get the
bee beard bees are not your typical bee
yes we
we selected we had selected those out
but if different
well you selected a different like a
certain hive that was very gentle very
mellow it was other personalities of a
hive yeah
you ever had any nasty run-ins with a
nasty personality hive oh yeah tell me
tell me a horror story well a couple
years ago we were working the hives and
I knew this one hive was fairly
aggressive mean it was we refer to it it
was an Africanized hive we knew that and
I wanted to find a queen to destroy the
queen and destroy the queen killer movie
so briefly Narnia but Africanized like
get tell us what that means well me okay
Africa they're from yep they're from
Africa we had some more they've
interbred with African bees and it's a
new thing it's a new thing yeah I mean
you know you're not African bees they're
African is done Africanized we had some
people that were geniuses
so they got breeze from Africa took him
to Brazil and they're gonna make the
super bee not the super beetle but the
super bee okay
they ran out of funding they said okay
and they unpacked their clothes and they
left laughter everything's set there
well the bees bees including the bees
the bees are fairly aggressive all right
long ago was this 20 years back at least
what would a super bee have been that
was the question nobody knows they but
they got mean you know they got mean
they they migrated they crossbred with
the bees in Brazil and everything and
then they started traveling and they
just traveled from Brazil right up
Central America right up into United
States and they're here in California
what would they do like well I mean what
are their what's their mo like what
makes them so mean well are we talking
like wedgies imminent wedgies yeah they
could get that bad they they could kill
people though yes
too many killer bees man I'm just
remember the 80s yeah a lot of
documentation were animals people have
died from
how big of an animal a horse yes three
years ago we lost two horses down in
Temecula so they're not years ago yeah
so they're not anymore vet venomous oh
yes
the are more venomous there are their
venom is a little stronger
but but the main thing is they're more
aggressive and easily agitated or like
what it's something very easily agitated
you can walk by him
knock on the the haibach's the tree or
the building they're in and they will
come they come by the thousands and they
follow you they fall along they can go
with you is up to a half a mile in order
to attack you attack you they attack
attack you tack animal attack I have
literally I wish I had taken pictures of
it I was using a motorized weed eater
cutting weeds I the grass and things hit
a Africanized hive in the ground they
were in a tree I didn't know it he we'd
eaten a tree yeah I mean you do it for
long enough it will come down yeah
like Paul Bunyan anyway I realized it I
left the motor running and laid it down
on the ground and they hovered over it
literally hitting the manifold and
frying themselves but they they are that
aggressive they didn't care that was
genius you left a decoy like a yeah like
a red herring yeah yeah I mean you know
you go a diversion
so you could run away and they all
attack your weed eater yeah I mean it
was you stood there and you just went
like you're committing suicide but they
didn't care that noise of onboard things
like that's a tractor driving by a car
can set them off made him so mad yeah so
okay but you had a run into what will
happen in with the hive well I went in
that hive and so and you were it was
just like you were being that this was
an Africanized hive that was gotten into
like one of my hives what am i normal hi
took it over it took it over correctly
well I had a full bee suit on and
everything in my gloves so I'm working
and I'm working and I'm working on it
and I'm getting stung I mean through the
suit yes you know it's one of the cute
things in life is when you buy a bee
suit you open it up you say oh I have a
nice new suit here but they give you a
little piece of paper on it and it says
this suit will not protect you from
stings and I always go then why did I
buy it you know but remember being told
that as I was putting on the beach yeah
earlier I feel totally safe yeah well
you know some things you don't need to
know but so I was working there a nice
getting stung I got a getting stung and
getting stung and I walked over to Bill
my partner and I said Uncle I quit get
me out of here I'm done I can't he goes
what's wrong I says man he goes oh my
guy at this point in time I'm hot
you've had a sunburn that's the hot I
had yeah I was blistering hot and I was
wringing my hands because they burned
through the gloves he took me down the
hill from where we was working took me
over to the Verdugo Hospital at that
time we were in the parking lot I take
my bee suit off I'm in my t-shirt and
shorts like I'm normally are mm-hmm I'm
beet red everyone everywhere and you're
burning burning you another pain not
pain just hot you know how many stings
do you think you'd experience at this
point well and when I finished up with
all this they bill on the felt and the
doctors out there they counted over 350
stings in on one arm Oh on one arm on
one arm and I had them on arms backs and
the chest and everything so you stripped
down to just your shorts and shirt in
the parking lot and then you stroll in
there you're like I'm I'm like a beat
hey-ya in the emergency room yeah and
the young lady says I said I've been be
stunning I need to see a doctor and not
just once and you didn't she said very
well you know you didn't have to give
him any paperwork gentleman walked out
and he said follow me
I pulled the big lotto numbers because I
walked
the next door and a doctor standing
there he had just come back from Central
America after six months studying of
what African bees and the bee stings
will do to a human body mm-hmm and he
looked over at me he says you've been
bee stung my god
he says 250 milligrams of this 250
milligrams of steroids and I goes my
wife's gonna be happy he goes no it's
not that within but you're not gonna
bulk up ya know I was praying so they
hang bottles they stick you with these
things and tabs you with that and I
jokingly to him I says oh you're
bringing in the microwave to serve lunch
he goes and the nurse says oh no that's
a cardiac resuscitation I goes oh well
we don't need that at this point if I
were gonna die said gee whiz I feel
tired I'm so sleepy she says you've had
300 milligrams of some sleeping thing
and I said oh okay I went to sleep or
occasionally they would wake me up about
10 hours later I'm waking up I'm thirsty
I'm ready to go I'm called my body is
cleared out and everything and they go
through the rigor of telling me how
things went and they said it was this
way that way we gave you a shot of this
and yeah your blood pressure started to
come down and this started to happen and
I says well fantastic doctor says
whatever you do continue it I goes well
I hope to because no he says I've seen
men women children 30 years younger than
you your age and they came in within
minutes they were dead well I'd never
realized it was that serious
I goes your kid and he goes you've had
be venom within your body it must be
pretty decent we cannot explain the
exact why but he says yeah you got a
guardian angel and he says keep him
happy because he keeping you happy and I
put my shoes on and I left that day and
my biggest fear never
never had anything to do with bees again
right
no that was my fear that I would become
highly allergic to it right so that okay
that is what happen is it it isn't like
you get some sort of immunity to it if
you get a lot of venom you actually
become more susceptible more susceptible
many beekeepers have worked for many
years and they use benadryl and things
like this to help but they've become
highly sensitive and they had to quit
the industry because of that hmm so we
waited a couple two or three days I went
down bill and I took some bees stung me
a half a dozen times we stood there if
you're inducted a test yeah we had to
find out what was going on right and you
don't know if he came to keep your job
yeah and you got your like a flat liner
man yeah I mean you know there was no
science to it just get stung by bees
again you know if it okay if it if you
keel over I'll put you in the truck take
you to the hospital again but nothing
happened and we looked at each other I
said I'll get my bee suit let's go to
work that's Ben and what's the worst
incident since then worst incident since
then oh gosh we've had numerous funnies
excitement things dumping bees on the
ground at two o'clock in the morning and
then trying to set them up when you got
oh three hundred thousand bees flying
all around she owned a spill on the
ground like like you know like well bill
was aerial yeah bill was picking up a
pallet that had four hives on it and he
turned and all for highs fall on the
ground and he turns to me and says stack
them up I'll get the rest of them and
now you have bees running up your pant
legs and all over you no bee suit in
this situation well I had a bee suit on
but they weren't a happy bunch of ladies
that got dumped on the ground from 20
feet in the air
you said everything back up they just
come back together yeah they came back
as a broom no I just used my hands
picked them up and put them into
different boxes and prayed that
everything would work out
we delivered some bees here last summer
up in the high desert up to the alfalfa
fields so you're diluting you
you're delivering these bees in order to
we had two processes there one was to
make alfalfa honey and also do
pollination for all the singers the
farmers use oh yes yeah so it's late at
night after midnight something like that
and we hadn't told the farmer that we
were coming in but we have been doing
this for eight nine years in his place
we pull in get out of the truck and his
truck comes flying up there real fast
jumps out of this thing he pulls out a
gun and I went whoa whoo hey what's
going on what's going on he goes oh I
thought someone was trying to steal my
hey well he had a problem with that and
we didn't know it and I'm standing there
well at one o'clock in the morning you
stand there and headlights are in your
face and a man's got a gun pointing at
you you pop tickle in your britches
about to say did you because I've always
thought I've never had a gun pointed at
me but I didn't mean either you know you
see the movies and there's the the one
guy that gets the gun pointed at him and
then he pees himself I was like I
wouldn't be that guy but I think I might
be that guy you know fortunately I
wasn't that guy I kept going I'm going
it's me it's me it's me it's me and he
goes oh yeah I would yeah and he relaxed
and I stood there and I looked over to
my partner bill and he goes I says oh he
goes Yeah right I mean we had about 12
octave higher in voice and I said that's
enough of this but it was guardian angel
having brushes with death man
I mean you know eventually it's going to
happen but I'm kind of prolonging it
right now I'm just stretching it out a
little longer I hope anyway now these
are these you're at risk she's here
tonight
these Africanized bees yeah I want to
talk about that a little bit more
because I was uh I was actually hiking
just like in a trail in the Verdugo
mountains and and I was I started I get
a little bit worried sometimes
especially when I'm with my kids yeah
I'm like okay well and we meet somebody
on the trailers like about a mile up we
think we we think we heard
snake so be careful so you think about
rattlesnakes and they're not thinking
about well you know I know there's the
ticks have Lyme disease around here now
that's something that's starting to
happen like so check yourself for ticks
and then I and then I'm starting like
and maybe they're you know we might run
into some killer bees out here some
Africa not african-american
so there could just be like a hive just
out in the mountains and on a trail
somewhere like are they everywhere now
everywhere from Texas Southern
California border far north is Fresno
the last reports are and you and if you
see a beehive in a tree you don't know
because you look at the hive and know
immediately which which one it was
no there's no K so it's it's the
behavior of the bees the behavior of the
bees is our first indication their
second indication if you want to take
the time and I don't know of anybody
that has you can catch a handful of them
and check the measurements of them yeah
they're only that there's they're
smaller and darker in color understand
I'm gonna have time to do that that's me
too I but I'm gonna be really vulnerable
with you here because the shepherd and I
started having this conversation it was
my eight-year-old son shepherd and I and
our dog Barbara okay and he was like
Barbara yeah she's named after Barbara
Mandrell and my my son was like dad what
are we gonna do if we run into one of
these hives of killer bees and I was
like well the thing is is they will
follow you and I told him I said I think
they'll follow you for like up to a mile
so I was a little bit off on my math
that's okay and I said so but the thing
is is we have to run because you can't
just stay there because we got a run and
I I read in that worst-case scenario
handbook that you can't just go and like
get under water because I'll just stay
above the water until you come back out
and keep stinging you so so then
Shepherd and I started talking about
like at what point would we leave the
dog behind you know because when it
comes to to me and my son and Barbara I
mean I'm sorry I love Barbara to death
but if somebody's got to go it's gonna
be the dog but I but I said Barbara is a
lot lighter than
I told Shepherd I was like Shepherd it
would have to be I would have to know
that you were in mortal danger before I
would leave the dog behind like it would
be it would seriously be like a mortal
equation I was like yeah I have to lose
the kid or the dog I'm gonna give the
dog up as you're running down across
there your son's gonna pass you up
because you're gonna be reaching for the
dog and he's gonna say bye dad I'm gone
and he splits you know but is that what
we're supposed to do just run like crazy
you cannot it's not like a black bear
would you just get real big and go yeah
and they run away from you 90 95 percent
of us aren't in any kind of physical
shape to run a mile and any at any speed
we could jog maybe a mile but to go full
blast out and run me yeah to run full
out for a half mile or a mile we
probably get about 200 yards and we're
on our knees patently like hoody and so
yeah my duty yeah I Kody yeah hooting
the Blowfish yeah I mean you're when
you're done but no but how does hoody
pant don't matter I've never heard of
I've never heard the same you haven't no
oh I've used this for years
panting hoody behind like hoody you know
about Darius Rucker though right yeah
country now yeah yeah don't say yeah if
you don't know that well I listen to the
music okay I don't know when you say
hoody well it's it is it's a very polite
way for me to not use any other language
that's offensive thank you and so I
always I add hoody to something where
somebody would say in a minute it works
real well I get a few pant yeah I'll be
panting like hoody cuz and they're
stinging you because you're not far
enough away yeah the bed so what so what
do we do you stay away you just if you
look up there in the tree you see bees
flying around
take a number Avenue of hiking so you're
saying that as long as you don't do
something to Mitchell directly agitate
them it's unlikely that
we'll have a problem if you don't
agitate the wife everything is happy
happy ok if you come in there and you
agitate you know could be a whole week
before it calms down okay 50 years a
practical knowledge either that or just
carry a running weedeater with you at
all times so you should diversion you
shouldn't do what we did as kids which
we would find oh yeah and we know you
know a stick at it oh yeah yeah there
was and then run across the Cape Fear
River and then up yeah it wasn't bees it
was it I guess I'll do because we could
see him it was it was a Hornet yeah and
it was a hole in the tree and I took a
stick and threw it and it wedged right
in there but what you would do is like
we were like already so it's like we
would creep up and you know you was let
it was like in 30 minutes of planning
and then it's like there's a count a
little overkill though you know here we
go in the 1 2 and then you throw it and
then we ran we bolted yeah nobody got
stung no we mean you me you and Ben
Hornets or mean and the sting hurts
worse but you did the one two three
you've lost all the thrill you should
have just stuck around for another five
minutes go before five and six
yeah and say ah I didn't go home tell
mom dad look at me I'm Dippold all over
from stings help you know yeah calamine
lotion all over my body
yeah so what um you know you like honey
nut cheerios yeah yeah there do you just
because they got a B on the box you're
going to talk about honey nut cheerios
like you eat him every day no no you got
him on the shelf at any given time yeah
there there there a couple times a week
maybe a couple times a week do you now
if you think if you want to be man you
you d them yo yeah they're great they're
just good okay that's it I like it so
they came first yeah they came before
the job so they're doing this thing now
they don't have the bees gone the bees
not on the packaging because they're
trying to tell people about all the bees
that are disappearing right uh-huh
well what's there if there
be there it's just a space it's a white
space where buzz I didn't even know this
I didn't know his name was Buzz you
isn't the bees name was buzz yeah we
almost did a we almost had them as a
sponsor but they wanted to do like a rap
with a Cheerios rap and we weren't in a
position to do that
I wasn't like no it was Nelly Nelly
Nelly had a Cheerios rap you know
knowing we'd do that yeah I can I could
neither collab with Nelly yeah so
they're doing this I love Cheerios so
they don't have buzz on there because of
the plight of the honeybees and they're
doing this thing where if you sign up
and we didn't do the sponsorship deal
with them I'm just I'm just saying this
I know and we're not currently doing it
and it's still not sponsored by them
neither mind they'll send you wildflower
seeds because they want plant like a
million whatever wildflowers yeah 100
million something crazy like that so I'm
sure you you're studied up on this bee
problem like what what's what's
happening
well it's affecting every bee and
beekeeper throughout the United States
and we're minimum we're losing 35% of
our hives every year some areas of the
United States are a little higher than
that the bees just died they're dead
gone
we as progressive people we have learned
how to use insecticides and sprays and
the EPA has reified things that killed
now they don't kill where they would
kill insects and things like this they
really this past year and said no they
won't do any harm
well that's correct it doesn't kill the
adult B but the spray they use then the
bees bring in the pollen and nectar and
they store it within the hive and these
near nikka tides that they were using
and fungicides they are into honey they
feed pollen and that to the growing
larvae mm-hmm they die because they
can't
but they have no resistance to these are
these are sprays that are like
insecticides weed killer type of stuff
fertilizer and the fungicides like
probably like originally tested them on
adult bees and they're like oh they're
fine but they're didn't well this has
been going on for years yeah and one of
the greatest things in the world is
you're a chemical company and you want
to sell your product so you do the
testing they did the testing in their
labs in their facilities and they came
up said no harm yeah there and they're
not biased so they're cool they're cool
so they did all that and then they filed
their paperwork and the pee folks all
read it and they go oh the chemist at
Monsanto and bear they said this is just
perfect and they go okay go ahead and
use it
no outside lab so ever and when the
outside labs or universities tested they
come back with opposite results and
you're seeing anecdotally or locally
you're seeing your doctor it's happening
everywhere all throughout the United
States because you guys get together all
you beekeeper yes your convention yes
will be key I didn't mean to sound no
Isis is not even a word you always come
up with those is that is this righteous
or is that righteous he's a he's a
righteous a man no uh
you bet your hoody we have conventions
throughout the year picture every
everybody rolling in without beard full
of bees on like hello bill hello yes and
you know do you know you know beard Tina
yeah we're very casual guys so I mean 50
miles in you say yeah that guy's a big
keeper and you go how do you know
you driving that flatbed truck towing a
forklift yep he's a beekeeper when you
get there your your your your sharing
your stories that this is not good this
is not good
dire straits you know we have professors
scientists are coming in from throughout
the United States Canada and Europe that
are
informing us of the studies that they're
doing on these different insecticides
and that are used it is ironic when you
look four years ago approximately they
had the same problem going on in France
mm-hmm
the farmers and beekeepers of France
went to their government it was a matter
of weeks weeks they took a vote in their
Parliament and said fine
the products are banned in France
immediately take him out of the country
home way and without and what happened
the bees came back the bees are starting
to come back much better because let's
clarify if that doesn't happen here you
know what what are the ramifications
well yeah and before you even answer
that why is it not happening here like
is it because of the big the big money
and like big AG like Monsanto they
lobbying and like keeping people from
like the legislation for going going
through is that what's happening well
that and the pen is mightier than a
sword whatever you can write on paper
and make it look documented Lee correct
it goes true better
Monsanto was the whipping post for many
and they have come on board with several
different people in the last few years
and they're changing their attitude and
they're actually putting their checkbook
in to play and starting stronger
investigation bear hasn't really jumped
on the bandwagon yet and they are the
biggest guys in town really yeah so they
we got to get them on board will we buy
we will the industry get them on board
Wow we do not have in the beekeeping
industry the power of money that they
have well you got Cheerios you got
Cheerios every little bit helps looks
pretty good on board yeah but it could
not be Cheerios you know honey nuts
cereals and all that you know only 30%
to 35% of the honey that is produced in
the United States is actually sold
here 70% or just less is imported from
outside of the United States
so the Honey Nut cereals and the honey
granola bars and all that mm-hmm
would not be a bit surprising that that
Honey came from Pakistan India Australia
Argentina 70% of that honey that we have
in the store
we consume came from outside of the
United States it is ironic it's just
ironic it's not but what happened was
what would happen what happened if this
if this problem isn't corrected well
it's been stated by very intelligent
peoples that if no bees no food they say
that the earth would probably last three
or four years I don't want to test the
possibility over the theory of that we
would have to go into being grain and
grass eaters and I don't think our
bodies can digest
I don't like grass my front yard I've
tried it yeah we would go into decline
and it wouldn't make any difference how
much money you have in the world or
what's your position in life was if
there's no food to eat there's just no
food to eat period so what I mean if
what can we do what can our listeners do
at this point to help it sounds too
maybe too simplistic sponsor the local
beekeeper go to his store go to his
farmers market and purchase his honey
that will help him maintain his business
we are losing like I say 35% or better
of our hives but we're losing much of
something even more important that is
beekeepers beekeepers that have been in
the business for the second or third
generations they're saying gee dad you
and Mom can retire I'm going to go I'm
40 years old I'm gonna go find another
job they're getting out of the business
that is all even a bigger loss well
here's to that because I think we
proven that beekeepers are pretty cool
and you know what I think we've got some
of your wares here honey yeah let's do
it you brought some right
yes and it was like it's like warm it's
like it came out of it it's not as warm
now but I don't know if it came out of
one car came straight out of a bee
before we came down I came down to do i
bottled this up just freshly bottled up
fresh yeah this is collected today yeah
we ate some of this before with Bill and
now we're gonna do it with you man it
was it was cool to hang out with you
that day it was just cool to hang out
here so so support I have the support
the local beekeeper
support to be local beekeeper to my
spoon technique you're talking plant
some wildflowers plant wildflowers yeah
get out there plant wildflowers educate
your family and friends out there that
you want to get the local honey like
we're eating right now this very nice
local honey it's excellent for those who
have pollen allergies but if it's sad to
know that all the bees had to die to
make this because it is the bee's blood
right
it's the bees blood right that's what
noni is no it's just a nectar from the
flower no nobody's died nobody's died
making it this honey no meat designed I
know it's just like the TV show and the
movies you know animal died at to prayer
them filming of this show I'm glad we
clarified that oh you have me too
I mean I couldn't keep up with them oh
that's good I might be able to convince
me that's not be blood but I still love
it mmm beet blood be guts something you
know B blood is actually yellow here's
all like that honey
that's kind of a brown amber mmm that's
good yeah it is good yeah it'll put hair
on your chest
I'm good there thank you I agree that's
why I have no hair in my head it fell
down thanks for coming in yeah you're
welcome thank you guys
[Music]
hope you enjoyed our conversation with
mr. Clyde STIs you can pick up the honey
that Clyde extracts from the the honey
comb over at Bill's bees calm it's good
we just ate so and support your local
Beast yes
you should eat local honey I mean that
isn't that that's important you're
supposed to for the allergies and stuff
so to do both of those things yes while
we're at it asking you to do things
leave a review on iTunes for this
podcast that's extremely valuable to us
comment on soundcloud if that's where
you're listening or on youtube if you're
listening and watching here your
feedback is always valuable mythical
beasts so use hashtag ear biscuits
wherever hashtags are found and if
you're watching on the this is mythical
youtube channel we always appreciate a
subscription it's free man all that talk
about cereal right now go get some well
I'm also thirsty
well there's milk in there
[Music]